listen guys let me just tell you the
answer to your financial woes my
financial woes comes in understanding
what we did that was dumb that caused us
to lose our money and so when you go
into a rent-to-own place and you rent a
washer and dryer and for what you're
paying per month within two or three
months you could have bought a nice used
washer and dryer but were you to pay
that rent to own all the way through you
would find yourself with an equivalent
of about a 24 or 24 hundred percent
interest rate you'll notice rent to own
is not in the rich end of town you'll
notice it's in the poor in attempt as a
matter of fact usually in the same
shopping center with the payday lender
because you need to get all your
financial mess overs in one location oh
let's put tidal pawn on the end of that
why don't we right there on the end of
it you can just tied up on your car yeah
let's lose our transportation which is
how we get to work where we make our
money and let's pledge that because
we're desperate scared freaked out and
didn't think other than thank God it's
Friday
hey weekend
Monday's oh god it's Monday and um I
have to be a grown-up I got grown up
bills five days this week after I've
been acting like I was a
fourteen-year-old adolescent all weekend
standing on my head and a beer can
seriously this is what folk do and I've
done it I've done made I've done all the
dumb things you can do with money now
I've not done payday lending I missed
out on that one and I haven't done rent
tone even back in those days I can add
even in my dumbest of days I could add
my most desperate of days I could add
but I've done things that are equivalent
of stupid a hair tie might do stupid you
know when I get broken desperate cuz I
deal with people who really don't have
my best interests at heart really they
want to do one thing touching off my
butt they just want to take me to the
cleaners
but what's interesting is you can do a
press release now in America and
somebody actually print it was something
as absurd as this language indicating
that somehow there's some level of
sophistication to payday lending
payday lending let me just tell you dude
I'm gonna just make fun of you if you do
payday lending I'm gonna accuse you of
your parents being cousins I'm gonna
wonder how many teeth are in your head
seriously stay out of those places I
know you get desperate you get scared
and right about that time you get stupid
I've done it all too but I'm gonna
really make fun of the number of brain
cells you have when you're going to
these places and I don't care listen if
you dress an ugly duck up you know what
it's still an ugly duck there's no way
around it lipstick on a pig still a pig
and so you can put the English language
with flowing phrases and a press release
payday lenders but you're still scum and
you're still scamming the poor hope I
wasn't unclear because I hate to be
unclear this is the Dave Ramsey show
you
you